on this episode I get salty and deep
this is
ask Gary B
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 165 of the askgaryvee
show
yesterday it was a rarity I actually
punted the show she said I'm not doing
it
I was extremely salty off the Jets loss
I missed my prediction only the second
time this year I am now no longer doing
any Jets predictions just not gonna do
it sorry not gonna make a decision on
the Jets dolphins I don't feel like I
have a pulse of this team anymore and I
don't think it I don't think that I
should continue to do it so I'm actually
still in a pretty salty mood
I think the Chiefs new walk into the
playoffs now with the Steelers so I
think ultimately my postseason dreams
have been squashed not looking to be
debbie downer just quite practical and
that's what I've got for you two and 65
guys I'm really upset thank God for
zinger there's a little bit of hope in
Nick's land I mean Jesus Christ it makes
have not been relevant since I've become
in the public Internet domain so I don't
even know if people think I'm a Knicks
fan or know that I am like yeah I like
literally never talked about it it's
been that shut down so that's got me a
little excited but that is very much a
consolation prize early our fourth round
our fourth pick overall producing for
the Knicks is what I'm now on this
Dolphins game is very important but
whatever so hope you have a great
Thanksgiving know that's coming up do we
do a show tomorrow okay
well I'll give you the hardcore
Thanksgiving thing tomorrow Sean Ryan is
here John televator Nation by yourself
Sean Ryan I'm a new media two years you
know you had a tremendous illustrious
intern career tremendous love that 17
that's amazing yes very much brother
gonna see it uh India no I'm you're sad
right it's like a sad vibe 165 somebody
left a great comment on Instagram that
the the green euro was over because I
missed the guests I thought that was a
good play to the golden era so big shout
out to that person I'm sorry I didn't
catch your name I'm not catching my jets
receivers are catching on stuff either
I'm really bad at like I I don't I
really don't know how to do the show I
mean I want to because I love you guys
so much but like I'm really pissed like
I like I there's been a lot of meetings
with executives that I've been punting
because I don't want to
I hate delivering bad news I've
scheduled them all this week got a bunch
of them later today and tomorrow cuz I'm
salty I'm in a good mindset to just
drill people in the face hmm any let's
get in the show trying to cheer it up I
know yeah
you put up a sassy Instagram photo
what's sassy you are sassy all right
let's go India let me ask India show
Evan asks why am i seeing an influx of
tech companies using billboards to
advertise slack snapchat Yahoo etc um
got him in a bad mood um Evan you're
seeing that because first of all you
should never put 100 and by the way I
speak in absolutes on this show so
please let me use this moment especially
for the people that catch this episode
or watch every show contextualize this I
love to talk definitively because I
don't think people take action and I
think it takes definitive stances to
kind of move the needle but there's no
situation where 100% of actions is the
right thing there's always a proper
hedge to everything I really really do
believe that in your execution and so in
marketing when you're in it Yahoo or a
slack or a snapchat and you've gotten to
that scale and you have that much money
in marketing budget there's only so much
you can allocate to 100% Facebook 100%
in somewhere I'm 100 percent digital
and when are these big consumer brands
there's a demo from the call it the 45
to 75 year old demo that people like
snapchat wants 45 year olds to use
snapchat like that's just straight up
and definitely Yahoo to mature brand
slack is a SAS enterprise software that
you know 50 to 49 63 me James Orsini
who's in his 50s as an executive in
Manor media he's helping make a decision
if we're gonna use slack along with a
genetics that in turn they want that
demo to be educated and their belief is
that billboards is a place to play that
look I'm not high on Billboard's I think
they're overpriced because I think
people looking at their mobile devices
but they're not worth zero and if you
know that you're going in and you're
gonna spend seven thousand dollars on
this billboard a month and you think
it's only worth twenty three hundred but
that twenty three hundred value is worth
it to you paying seven thousand follow
me here then that's the right thing I
mean like you know that's it I mean like
like you know if it's worth spending a
thousand dollars on a dinner with the
prettiest girl you ever went on a date
for for the ROI of a kiss if you decided
that the kiss was worth a thousand well
then it's worth it that's what I think
on Billboard's which is you know if they
decide it's worth seven thousand even
though they know that they're overpaying
well then that's what you do and so I
think I think you're gonna see more
television commercials for that reason
from internet companies you're seeing it
within being uber when you saturate one
medium you have to go to another place
where you get more upside once you crush
digital like those companies have over
paying for traditional has more value to
you so it's the timing in which those
companies deploy the media they didn't
start that place they first got a better
ROI you're getting all these people
digitally for call it eight bucks a head
eighteen bucks a head well now it
started cost us thirty eight dollars a
head because we've gotten everybody and
we can't get no mores so we'll go over
here will be fifty two because at least
we can get new people and it's now worth
fifty two for us that's why that was
really good considering the anger I feel
in my body
thanks India oh wait what what I wanna I
want to uh I mean Sean's just sitting
here might as well do a little maybe
Facebook
kopi scope hold this okay look at it all
right Anthony Anthony asks you recommend
working for free but how do you know if
someone is just trying to get free stuff
and passing it off as exposure
you don't fine you don't and that's the
point like not everything has up side
every single time you do it
it's a net net score you do it 38 times
do you rocket you didn't move ease for
free besides me and this just just
popped in my head how many 24 people
that looks like my profile how many that
look like my profile - right and then
you got a bunch after right that's right
so how did those 20 work out for you
yeah I don't expect you to say that like
I'm cured like one one one one pot it
and then how about mine so you know I
mean so I think I think that uh I think
that it's uh I I think you don't I think
look you can look into people's
backgrounds see their actions I would
tell you off of the you know exposure
and hyperbole of D rocks free work on
this show I'm probably in a better
position today than I was two years ago
to get people to want to do free work
because they're like well I want to be
that so you can look into people's
history and if you can but you just
really don't you have to use your
intuition like you don't mean meetings I
go and pitch new business and then
others I don't and I'm making a judgment
call like it's a use of my time my
biggest asset and was it worth going for
three hours and flying it was worth a
day flying pitching the business and a
meeting get it that was a bad judgment
call but then sometimes it works out
it's a net-net game this insanity for
the short term ROI of every action is so
goddamn broken what's his name again
Anthony that you know I think way too
many people are crippled you don't you
don't know a lot of
you don't know almost everything like
serious like like what do you know in
life like is this the right College is
this the right friends this is the right
boyfriend like you know anything you
make decisions and you just live with
them you counterpunch the reality work
to this freelance high ground of like
that
it's supplying the man mother father's
like if there's people who want to do it
and that's just the [ __ ] yeah I'm super
salty Jeff seid over for one now we're
five and five that means we've gone one
for four you math strugglers out there
Thomas why the questions get listen ya
wanted to be on the show you got 165 I
mean it's just you didn't know you
didn't know what's gonna happen you
didn't know that's some random football
team that you don't give a crap about
change the by but your answers on the
show that you liked sorry Thomas asks
how would you manage having a higher
demand in production capacity how do you
manage expectations when you have two to
three months of latency you hire
freelancers and you work on lower mark
foot alright okay you hide are
freelancers and you work on less margin
you go to your best people that are
there for the long haul and you ask them
to work more hours so if they work seven
hours and they work 14 hours you can get
more [ __ ] done you adjust you like you
know the end you know if you're you you
can't be late for clients if they want
it and you're late you lose project
manager shaking his head right I mean
like like yeah I mean like look here's
something that's subjective the creative
oh I like this video oh I like this
sweater oh I hate this sweater well like
your yellow shirt though some things are
subjective what's not subjective is it's
due on Wednesday oh we got it we'll give
it to you in a week later they don't
feel good so you either outsource with
freelancers and you make a lot less
margin cuz it costs more per hour or
bites into your margin or maybe you lose
money but you want to deliver for the
client and you keep them longer and you
play lifetime value
the ROI on every single thing or you
asked your team to step up or you step
up if you have that capability I'm not
scared to make a video I know Jason and
D Rock can make it better but like I'll
do it Matt asks if you could change one
part of Facebook's API for marketers and
business pages what would it be I don't
give a crap about this question i
like-like-like India but I think I'm now
playing into my character of this show
if I would sum dissing myself screw you
Gary
I mean look man I think it's a great
question it's very tactical I think we
as marketers would always take more data
I want everything right like if I could
follow people around I would do that
like I would like so the truth of the
answer is any piece of data that they're
not giving me like I would love the data
of first name data I want to target
people by their first name I don't think
you can do that right now so I'd like to
reach out to every Gary and be like yeah
it's me Gary as well let's be bullies
all Gary's so I would love to target
people by first name and and I don't
think you have that capability yet so
that would be one and there's probably
15 other cohorts that I'm not completely
up-to-date on of what we have access to
and what we don't but I would love to
have more access more data points
whatever if I if I had the time to sit
down right now and I'm because it's
moving all the time some if I went to
the the analytics and paid team right
now and said okay let's just do a quick
update whatever the first highest-value
data point on an individual is that I
don't have access to would be the answer
to this question and that would be the
thing that I would have a creative idea
against then I don't have access to like
first-name targeting like that'd be
funny right like India if you saw that
in your stream you're like hey it's me
India like just gathering all India's
you believe that's kind of cool
seriously yeah how many Indians were
that's awesome what nationality are most
India's
yep that's really cool like me
personally following them around oh yeah
I want to follow you around periscope
what else that's it
Josh Josh asks how clearly do you need
to see the end goal and the path to get
there before you can begin clarity
before hustle the clarity is everything
if you don't know where you're going you
will get lost
mmm I'm sure somebody said that before
but I first time I've said I like it
it's like like you just uh the clarity
is everything like no question my
clarity on my professional goal which is
the vanity professional goal of buying
the New York Jets but more importantly
the depth of that which is the process
of trying to buy the Jets has absolutely
and then my real one that I don't talk
about that often but one so on the show
of like getting everybody to be guilted
into going to my like show and you'll
come to my funeral right awesome so like
like you know that to me allows me to
interact the way it that's what like
making sure that everybody comes to my
funeral is probably the reason I need to
get salty to have like the tough
conversations because I'm just I'm soft
that way because I just love so I just
love I also hate I hate football
so I think the clarity really matters I
think a lot of you and I've been reading
a lot of your comment specially
Instagram I'm really deeply entrenched
there right now so start leaving more
comments because that is a hundred
percent of place I'm going to see them
uh and by the way actually let me take a
step back thank you so much Boehner Nick
the real answers to who are you
you guys saw like deep like deep
I'm gonna go review and read everyone
one more time right probably forty
percent I'm gonna read them all because
I'm just too appreciative that you
actually did that there was some deep
stuff some very real stuff Oh
join my email newsletter we're pushing
that right now ding link it Stephan in
the in the YouTube and the that YouTube
in that Facebook
a lot of you don't have your clarity a
lot of you are looking for the vanity or
the short-term things out of pain out of
ambition and I have empathy for both of
those things the truth is you just got
to know and I'm essentially somebody
left an Instagram photo of like boring
about what I was posting because he was
like basically saying look I'm over
trying to build a business like I travel
a bunch I don't make that much money I'm
happy as hell and I was like I like my
bottoms like I'm pumped like just so
everybody knows like I don't know if you
guys are getting tricked by the facade
this whole show my whole energy is like
I just want people to be happy like
people pay attention for to me because I
think they're gravitating towards
believing that business success will
bring them a certain level of happiness
but like I just want everybody no
forever for the record maybe this is a
medium piece for the record while I'm
salty I'm you can be punked as hell at
forty nine thousand dollars a year and
boy boy do I envy the crap out of that
boy do I envy more than anything in the
world somebody who's wired internally to
be able to get a commoditized job where
there's a lot of them to make a 40 to
$60,000 a year pay to then live a lower
middle class or depending on what part
of the world you live in that you're
very excited about just checking the box
on those 40 hours that is not where your
passion lies come home and your whole
life revolves around the bowling team
drinking beers with your buddies that
you went to high school with that never
left town I mean these are cliche things
but I mean dead goddamn serious right
now like what the hell's wrong with that
that's awesome like crap that is
tremendous
like that's the best like you like I
know this because I know how upset I am
about the Jets that's something I care
about I almost don't care about anything
else this way and it's a better life I
match happy have a person outside of my
football life like it's great like like
you know what is it like what does that
whole thing like and I being naive is
bliss or what does the same ignorant
like there's truth to that meaning like
and that's not it's like simplicity is
delicious that's going to like
simplicity is delicious like like what
is possible please don't
don't think you're watching the show
because I'm trying to rob Ryu - working
90 hours a day I'm just telling you what
it takes to make a lot of money in a
hyper-competitive business world in 2016
I'm not telling you that's the light to
happiness the light to happiness is to
be so self aware of what makes you tick
and go do that but don't complain that
you're not making it when you're not
doing actions to make it like I don't
complain about missing my family you
will not hear me say that because I'm
not entitled to say that because my
actions don't map to that pain you're
just doing the reverse you're
complaining like what was me unfair it's
not unfair it's talent and work period
you think you want to call that your
parents had sex in a moment that turned
you into a human and didn't give you a
certain talent that you subjectively
wish you had cool you think that's
unfair fine
I think you're a [ __ ] because I
think the fact that you even became a
human being is the greatest thing that
ever happened but you're more than
welcome to say like oh I'm not the
prettiest or why don't I have Beyonce's
voice like fine like like [ __ ] I wish I
was six nine and can dunk and pass like
I wish I was that LSU kid light-skinned
freaking got moves like great but it's
not what I have like know who you are go
execute but if you sit and watch the
show on your phone right now on the
subway and you're happy because you're
so happy where you're going right now
whether to work or leaving work and
going to the Knicks game or the lowly
Nets game or your darts championship
be with your homies like that's the only
thing that matters cool yep great
question of the day do you think the
Jets can win on Sunday I can really use
it I you know Steve Ross owns dolphins
he's my business partner so we play him
it's usually a big game we crush them in
London not so confident this time around
but that's the joke
here's the real question of day what
wine are you drinking at Thanksgiving
and this is a great time lurkers I just
gave you a very compelling
heartfelt 3-minute rant that I thought
was really good I really really really
really think that you should leave a
comment and say hello because I'm going
to the holiday weekend I will have some
time to really look I'm drawing a line
this sand
every goddamn lurker please come out and
leave a comment on Facebook and YouTube
I need it I need it
you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them